institutional investors Kevin we got
bigger and busier and busier
our exchange community has grown since
1792 - more than 1,350 more than 650
member firms more than 2,500 offices
more than 64,000 people handling the
orders that funnel into this central
market where financial institutions
direct a great volume of transactions to
buy and sell listed securities each
minute the institutional investor has an
average of twelve thousand dollars of
new money to invest twelve thousand
dollars a minute there are a good many
ways that institutional investors are
taking best advantage of this versatile
market created by broad public
participation and because most of your
orders are executed in the regular
auction market let's take a closer look
at it starting with a quick rundown on
the men who transact your everyday
business on the floor
these member floor brokers for instance
who are usually partners in the member
firms trading for you at the post where
the stock you want to buy or sell is
assigned two or more brokers trading in
an issue we call a crowd the specialist
whom you can pick out because he
frequently refers to this book the
reporter who records transactions
reported to him by the seller and sends
the stock symbol size and price to the
ticker governors and floor officials who
oversee all trading activity
the specialist clerk and the brokers
clerk whose telephone links the floor
through the order room to the man you
know best your own broker because you
and he are both professionals your
member broker can help you make the best
use of the market in carrying out your
investment decisions suppose you had an
order of moderate-sized it could be
handled all at once
or in a flow in flow out series of
transactions the auction market is the
place for it
here's what would happen your order is
relayed to the clerk on the floor who
calls for the firm's floor broker by
placing his number the broker goes to
his clerk and picks up the order
he goes to the post gets the quote and
joins the crowd as other brokers bid or
offer with him he states his offer in a
loud clear voice a sale is made and
recorded there are no written contracts
the brokers word is enough news of the
sale is spent to the ticker and word is
sent to your member broker he reports to
you that your order has been executed
but your broker also knows that your
needs may be different more complex
possibly the block is a large one or
maybe you want more speed your firms
floor broker may decide to enlist the
specialist each specialist handles an
average of eleven stocks with market
activity constantly flowing around him
the specialist performs the first of his
two important functions acting as a
broker's broker when your floor broker
cannot immediately complete an order at
an acceptable price he can entrust the
order to the specialist who then becomes
a member of your market team obligated
to get you the best price he can the
order is then entered in this
confidential book here's the way it
works at each price level he enters in
sequence the orders that brokers leave
with him
when this order is finally executed the
specialist will cancel the entry and
notify the broker the specialists work
his records and his books are
continually checked by the exchange
because he knows his issues because he
knows the market the specialist is able
to perform his second job helping to
keep that market fair and orderly though
stock prices rise or fall because of
supplier demand it is the specialists
function to keep the spread between bids
and offers and price variations between
sales as narrow as circumstances will
permit as a result he's usually buying
for his own account when the market is
falling or selling when the market is
rising but he may buy or sell only when
there is no public order on his book at
that price but this flexible market is
also designed to accommodate the
marketing of large blocks in weighing
your joint decision your broker may know
that there is more stock available than
the quoted market shows because he is in
such constant touch with the activity on
the floor but beyond this he can also
help institutional investors buy or sell
with seven special block procedures the
specialist block purchase or sale our
procedures you and your broker might be
able to use in the specialist block
purchase the floor broker is responsible
for executing your order
though he tranzec sit on the exchange
floor it is not a part of the regular
auction market your broker offers your
block to the specialist who consults his
book and makes a net price bid somewhat
away from the current auction market
here is in all special procedures
exchange approval must be obtained
before the transaction can be completed
this can usually be done very quickly
when a specialist blocked transaction is
completed there is no print on the
ticker your broker earns a single
commission
the exchange distribution or acquisition
are other procedures you might use in an
exchange distribution your broker goes
to work to round up the buy orders you
need
when the necessary total has been
accumulated the orders are then crossed
in the auction market the seller pays
all brokerage costs
there has been no advance publicity but
after the cross is made word of the
exchange distribution is carried on the
ticker
you might decide on the special offering
or bid when you use the special offering
your broker sends out notice in advance
the ticker carries words of buyers in
600 cities and quickly brings to the
market to buy orders you need
the buyer gets his stock at net price
the seller pays commission to the buyers
brokers the secondary distribution like
a new issue allows your broker and other
brokers in the securities industry to
buy portions of a large block for resale
to the public or for their own accounts
usually after trading hours the buyer
gets his stock at fixed net price no
Commission
so to help buy or sell large blocks of
stock the New York Stock Exchange offers
the institutional investor a choice of
seven special block procedures for on
the sell side three on the buy side
seven special procedures supplementing
the flexible central auction market and
when you use the regular auction market
there is no need to split up your block
you may designate one broker to execute
your entire order but you may still
direct him to share the Commission with
other member firms this is one way to
keep the price from getting away from
you on the floor however let's assume
you insist upon dividing your block
among three brokers you give this broker
the first part of your order to sell
there's a down after the execution is
reported to you you give the second part
of the block to another broker another
down take and the third part to still
another broker
you'll just become your own worst enemy
one broker completely in your confidence
knowing exactly what you wanted could
have been much more efficient but the
real test of a markets efficiency is not
how it operates when things are going
well but how it functions when something
unexpected happens
in times of crisis the exchange is open
every minute of every business day its
member firms are available to customers
their liens are open to the floor the
specialists are at their posts ready to
team up with your broker ready to do
their part in meeting the exchanges
objective to keep the market orderly
the emergency passes
the auction market created by public
orders responsive to your needs man by
experts
it is central flexible liquid each day
this market handles more than 125
million dollars in buy and sell orders
it's special procedures its experienced
market teams provide you with all the
techniques all the services to carry out
your investment decisions